Okay. It's time for hatred, male hatred, male,
of course, the much loved and much despised
segment in which a professional voiceover
artist does. Interpretive readings of the
hatred that mail that I get. This week's is
a special one, but first, just a reminder
about what hatred mail is
because we cling to our guns and our God,
but somehow totally
cool with a billionaire who wants to assault
our wise Patriot mail written by patriots.
Who, Hey David Pakman because America and
because freedom.
Okay, so this week's hatred mail, there's,
they're just a really great word in it. I,
I'm not even going to say anything else, but
let's take a listen. Let's take a look.
David Pakman spends 50 minutes dancing around
semantics like every other NPC. David Packman
is the epithelium of NBC journalism. Why is
Parkman audience weaponized autistic? You
are Jewish and this administration is antisemitic
watts, yet another rand from our resident
communist pig. Mr Pacman.
Yeah, at home. This is so funny. Epitope of
course is a mispronunciation of the word epitome
and if you don't know the word and you see
it spelled correctly, you might think it's
pronounced to epitope. And I remember every
time I hear that word, a pronounced epitope,
I think back to when I was like, I don't know
how old I was watching Msnbc in this report
or Thomas Roberts, who I'm sure he's a great
guy, uh, was just reading off of his teleprompter
and he referred to something as the epitope
of something else. And I immediately realized,
I'm sure that it was spelled correctly on
his prompter, but he clearly doesn't know
what that is. Uh, much like bill O'Reilly
not recognizing what it means for sting to
play us out this evening, uh, in that infamous,
let's do it live debacle, a Thomas Roberts
not recognizing the word epitome.
Uh, but, um, I, I think that, uh, we don't
really need to say too much else other than
NPC. Come on. That's so three months ago.
It's like the cock of six months ago. No one's
using the term NPC anymore. Uh, was anyone
even really using it seriously to begin with?
Let me remind you the number one way to fight
hatred prism in your own community is to use
the coupon code hatred at 40. When you sign
up for a membership on our website. Now, this
is so funny. We started the coupon code hatred
40 years ago as sort of like a throwaway.
I said I'll just create a hatred mail related
coupon code for membership. I'll mention it
only during hatred at Mel's segments and let's
see if anybody uses it to sign up. Probably
very few people will. Every week, five to
seven new members sign up using the hatred
at 40 coupon code and it was something that
no one really thought would be that successful.
So the way it works is the membership of your
choice@wwwdotjoinpacman.com you apply the
coupon code, hey tree at 40 that's h a t r
I o t 40 and the price drops 40% you get 100%
of the member benefits including the bonus
show and everything else, but you get a 40%
discount. It's a beautiful thing and I look
forward to welcoming new members signing up
with that code.